so on this week's show with the
government saying they're going to
abolish section 21 what impact is that
going to have on us as landlords in the
news five students successfully sue and
win back fifteen thousand pound in rent
from their landlord and we're gonna be
answering all your property related
questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
hi almost leads I'm Alistair Cunningham
and welcome to property investors
podcast it has been a good week for
Kurzweil have Easter last week
yes meant we had four days completely
off and literally I did nothing than you
know what I say nothing I mean I went
into the park and things I was but
pretty much I didn't know what the chill
out for days I just slept for like nine
hours a day in a night you know a lot of
sleep a lot of rest is awesome had a
good time okay my wife took the took the
most advantage of me being at home and
she said like you're home for days we
need to do some stuff so we literally we
empty we ripped the bathroom out because
we're having a new a new bathroom put in
so we ripped the bathroom and you
actually it yourself filled the skip
emptied the bathroom so it's just
Lucille with water pipes coming at the
ground and so we've done all that we
ripped a lot of decking up in a garden
because we're having a dip the garden
like you're I loved it me it was good a
lot of it I don't mind a bit of hard
work just yeah it's easy just hitting
things with hammers it's cool good man
no good for days awful yeah sounds
sounds amazing right so we'll be talking
this week first of all about the
government announcing they're going to
be abolished in section 21
okay so first of all yeah really simply
let's explain what they are so if you're
a landlord there are two different ways
that you can serve notice on on a tenon
yeah so your first is section 8 now
let's look at the pros and cons of both
of them so section 8 means that they
need to have broken the contract in some
way so not paid their rent sort of
something let's trash the house
something like that in which case you
can serve them a section 8 and you can
give them but somewhere between two
weeks and two months notice so you can
go choose how much noise you give them
has to go through the courts well it
have to go through the course this is
the problem if they say no I disagree or
no they it can then go to court and the
problem is is that when it goes to court
it takes forever yeah and even if the
court says are going to move that and
then they don't you have to call again
and it can be it can be a bit of a
nightmare
the alternative is section 21 yeah
now with section 21 you don't need any
grounds so a certain that you you can't
you can't have a six month contract and
then kick them out during a six month
contract for example no no there would
be so you would give them see let's just
see they took a six month contract yeah
and their tenancy come to an end April
the forest mm-hmm you could say to them
in March at the end of your term you
gotta ask you to vacate the premises yes
so let's say for example you decided
that you're a tenant in they've been
there for six months then you decided
that this property wasn't great you
wanted to sell it yeah so you served
them a section 21 or you start trying to
sell it in the service section 21 look
there anything wrong no you're just
asking them to Vicky yeah or if I don't
know I'm trying to think of a good
reason now a lot of the time this is the
thing as someone who's run a letting
agency a lot of the time you'll use
section 21 even when they broke the
contract because you don't want the
hassle of having to prove that they are
bad tenants or having to prove that
having to go through the courts and all
that hassle so you just didn't look like
them two months they got to get out it's
fine so a lot of people use section to
anyone even when they could use section
home right so that's the basics of what
we're looking at here yeah now what the
government is saying is is that
landlords are misusing section 21 to get
rid of tenants for reasons such as the
tenant keeps asking moaning about the
house because it's a crap house so
basically they're misusing it and for
when tenants are like you know
complaining about the house being
rubbish now I know it's for when tenants
I'm warned about like if 10 mourns about
damp or something that says that the the
house needs decorating or if the rather
than fix it they say evict it and put
another tenant in there yeah yeah
misusing it now I also they want longer
they want longer length of stays see I
don't believe that's the case I haven't
really seen much of that no I think most
of time in the user section too
one is to save the hassle of using a
section eggs because they're a bad
tenant in my you know I'm only looking
for my landlords point of view here but
getting rid of section 21 to me it would
be terrible I agree with you because it
was that what's alternative so you've
got a 10 in yeah what is the alternative
that you want they should see your
there's to see yourself on your houses
or I'm selling one of my properties how
do we get rid of the tenant then because
you don't really want to be sale on the
property with tenants no you you'd
rather have a vacant property so how do
you get rid of them good question I
think there's just clarify a law this
hasn't been enforced yet no right
there's more enforcement right now is
and we're being you know we're talking
about it
who knows what's good what if it's
anything like the government it could be
five years away there's no there's no
please
yeah breaks it was supposed to happen
that didn't happen yeah you know I mean
the it could be a long long time away I
know it's not as big deal as bricks it
but it it could be a long time away or
it could change slightly and tweaked
slightly so I know the residential
landlord Association are kind of
fighting this at the moment yeah so I
had a chat with them earlier and I said
I said the same situation so I've got a
property if I want to sell it and they
said we'll look right now you can sell
it it's fine you can use section twenty
one I said well what about when it comes
in
and they said well we don't know yes we
don't know a when it's coming in and we
don't know what the ramifications it
seemed that the government of sort of
just jumped on the bandwagon and just
push this through push this policy
through and not really considered it I
think it's more of it's such a
protection of the the tenants and yeah
that's basically against cruel and lords
and well private landlords get screwed
left right and center every every which
way but my concern is if it does come in
it potentially could make it an absolute
nightmare because this is the thing like
I understand that the tenant lives in
the property and I'm a tenant yeah so I
can look at it I I feel I can look at it
objectively so where aren't where I'm
living right now I'm in a six month
contract I'm also a landlord but where I
live right now I'm a six month I'm in a
six month contract in the six months the
landlord said to me look I'm gonna
resell the property he's your team ups
notice I kind of think that's fair
enough yeah you be though his property
is his property if he doesn't want me
there then as long as it does it fairly
and he says Luke me too much snow is
yeah it's fine
I agree with you I think there's too
many people are they loved playing the
whole victim and they love any reason to
moan and say it's his home and you are
renting off him and your internet you
know if you know to me it's just
mind-boggling is this ridiculous I think
I don't have to have done anything
terrible to be it's not I I don't feel I
have the right to live in that house
know I had the right to there for six
months ago signed a six-month contract
they don't own that property they're
just renting it and I think as long as
the landlord's fair and gives them
suitable notice that he wants believe
who are they to say that if you were a
member of Sky Sports yeah they are by
the way just so you know we're not doing
Sky Sports anymore yes it's not very
good it's not a very good investment for
us I couldn't be like well no you are
doing it still yeah because it's their
service they choose whether they want to
provide the service or not they're a
football field if you want to play in it
you have to play by their rules maybe
they could bring in a rule that said if
the tenant hasn't this is the problem
though because let you may you might
want to bring in a rule that says the
tenants not doing anything wrong to
avoid discrimination against the person
if they evict the tenant to sell it then
they have to sell it they or at least
give the tenant an option to move back
yes what you don't what what would be
unfair is if they were discriminating
but mind you they wouldn't put them in
the first place
discrimination is gonna come at that the
thing is right there is some long long
stand in long term tenants so I
personally know somebody that's rented
the same house for 16 years yeah and
they've got no intention of going
anywhere to them that's their home even
they don't own it they pay their rent
every month they're brilliant tenants
did they create the house to do
everything so then suddenly if they were
served section 21 for no fault of their
own
is that fair well is if the landlord
doesn't want to rent it out anymore yeah
I mean it's it's just the harsh reality
of life isn't it if you don't this is
ready you don't have security you've
also got flexibility the reason I love
renting a like the flexible rules
of everything we've discussed this
before yeah so that you like Wrentham
because you've got the Flex you can't
have it every which way
no I service the landlord's running a
business and that's their product yeah
yes and I do agree with you as you say
there lieutenant my landlord you know
they might do something that isn't a big
deal but the landlord might not like it
so for example they might just keep the
house really messy yeah is that grounds
to unlike the guard and overgrow is that
rat grounds to evict someone yeah
is it I'm my opinion yeah I think so too
but is it under a section 8 you could
you go to court as they just keep the
ground everything is this is a very fine
line isn't it but I personally think it
is because Luke take my properties which
is why I grew very high standard which
is why when I said in reaction to anyone
is so important because at the end of
the day the landlord is not going to
evict the tenant for no reason no of
course it's not because they're gonna
lose they're gonna void if he's getting
rent every month and it's on time and
there's no problems why would he evict
you there's a reason for them evicting
you my question is section 21 s gone not
yet but when it does go hopefully when
it's gone yeah
then what yeah what then what do we do
but as that's the question the problem
isn't not many people know the problem
is we don't know we don't know what's
gonna happen so we don't know a when
it's gonna come in is that a piece of
are they gonna replace it just a case of
the government I wouldn't see section
21s no longer valid
which means you you cannot evict a
however section 6 you can now section 18
there's gonna be the new section 21 but
just a little tweak neither the
government like sometimes they have a
rule change here but something else does
do that they're hitting private
landlords left right and center at the
moment was new it was new stroke this is
true so anyway interesting so talking
about evicting because I saw that Samuel
did a video yeah last last week talked
about evicting tenants that trashed the
houses yeah he was talking about I think
the video was tired what was it titled
trash and tenants trashed my house or
something yeah
I don't know I'm asking the video before
but he said something like that okay
yeah so um he's talking about how to
eliminate the risk of people trashing
your properties have you ever had a
property trashed no not properly trash I
don't know many people have to be honest
no I know a lot of landlords I know
people have had probably is left in our
not a great condition but not to the
point where the kitchens have been
ripped out and there's holes in the
walls and things I saw a news article
for someone who did service
accommodation nice party
did you see this me whose was it
what was the guy's name remember is he
16 year old kid had their birthday pie
they're basically the parents just hide
it and went knock yourselves out of
course it is it wasn't their eyes and
they did forty five thousand pounds
worth of damage yeah what would you do
with the parents what would you do with
the person that that apartment
bailiffs a big one straight through it
I'd be calling for court money call him
online get them through high court
bailiffs at the front door mate but
they'd be saying but it wasn't even my
kid it was the other kids some of their
parent they're responsible they booked
it I'd be ruthless I don't I'm ruthless
with this sort of stuff if I can you
imagine ruthless I know he's cleared
insurance I said yeah but it's just the
inconvenience do you know that core not
sure he finished a property in Liverpool
right by hand for your service
combination big six bedroom house spent
like three or four weeks doing it the
first guests trashed it literally it
went live on like a Friday the first
guests moved in Friday night this was
several months back and they literally
wrecked it and there was painting on
there there was writing on the wall
there was mess everywhere there was beds
were broken and it's just he spent all
that time and effort getting it right
that's just her and once she actually
got rid of all the mess it wasn't as bad
as it looked but like Majan gone into
that you spent all your hard-earned
money in timing it and then literally a
first gear selector and then your heart
sings tonight you you lose a bit more
[ __ ] now unfortunately he sort of he
looks at it completely as a business so
he doesn't get to entire to it and his
evening just fixed it but yeah just
really just not nice so at the moment
what with Samuels tips then on how to
to turn one of his main tips were don't
be a motivated landlord so one thing
he's seen is when you're so desperate to
get somebody in there that you'll just
take anybody and I think that's the the
key point I think the same applies for
service combination you can be quite
yeah and can be quite especially if
you're over Airbnb you can only accept
people that have had multiple take the
love.what reviews and all sorts and I
got a bad review from Airbnb the
generally peed me off right because I
did anything wrong wasn't for that
cottagey stared at an Oxford was it oh
yeah it gave me a bad review you know
the one that left the key in the door oh
yeah right
so it got through I got an email through
from Airbnb saying and oh the host has
left you review in order to see his view
of you yeah so I was like ah if you wait
seven days you can read this review but
then you can't leave a review oh really
oh yeah I didn't know that so I was just
like ah kind of a see what his review is
just interesting isn't it you know I
mean thought about it was like I was who
he's written so I gave him with you gave
him like five stars the dick I wish I
hadn't she's giving him like a one star
and like he was like aren't there are
nice people but the left loads of
rubbish in the kitchen right with the
rubbish we left though was in the bin
yeah the bin was full because there was
a lot of rubbish but we basically filled
his bin but we've been there like two
weeks yeah like calm we hoovered it we
cleaned it well I say we Anna did Hoover
it cleaned it she did a great job it
looks looks immaculate when we left I
thought if it was one of my service I'd
be like wow they've done a really nice
job leaving it what it's only recently
gone up so I think I assume he's only
just started doing it and he's just got
ridiculously high expectations and wait
until he gets someone that he's a bad
tenant yeah I am had Airbnb of just the
the suspended my one of my properties
for five days
they paused the the listing provided
days because I go somebody left me are a
bad review recently
now you've been to the property you've
been there yeah it's the countryside
yeah so it's not a Mac it's not which
one we should we say to Matt now you've
got one yeah yeah so it's not like a
city centre apartment it's an old rustic
building in the middle of countryside
yeah it is yeah right way going with us
so there was a mouse got into the
property in the countryside minutes I'm
not unheard of is it and there was one
Mouse dropping on the stair just one and
she left about did we seen there was
mice droppings in every single room and
it was disgusting and things that are so
I sent my cleaner in I kind of think
she's got a point
no no no come on I sent my cone around
that no I sent my cleaner in and I said
Lee go and have a look at it take
photographs of all the rooms up close
and then propagate of town I want to
have a look at this and all he could
find was one Mouse dropping and that was
on the stairs there was no most robbers
everywhere else in the countryside man
come on
I would like would you like Nick
wouldn't mind one Mouse come on it's not
even it's not like there was mice
droppings everywhere and every room
there was one mace dropping and as a
result the the if everyone else says
great apartment immaculately clean
and then there's one no bed say there's
one most drop and she left that she's
she made out the place was littered in
mice droppings and it's like come on
it's right if they suspended my account
until they spoke to me I would be
annoyed of that review going at their
phobias for their mine anyway so I when
I went to when I went to Frankfurt
we there was a restaurant like a
Vietnamese restaurant I've got a little
video after show you actually laughs and
we nearly went there for dinner but we
didn't rent the Vietnamese restaurant
opposite it later on that evening we
were walking past and I saw a mouse in
the window but you know like we're all
we're all that the food it was like I
was hair I was just like oh my days like
that is just
he's probably lucky wasn't Sarah's
gusting so I'm not in the window to try
and tell the guy you know there's a
mouse like and he was just like no we
could
closed they in German he couldn't speak
English and I obviously can't speak
German he's just like that and I was
like it's that Mouse no no so I was
trying to like an impression of a mouse
to show him there was a there's a look
at your impression well yeah he didn't
get it anyway he just laughed and walked
away but yeah I don't I don't know no
it's great a minute it's great but yeah
I think my tenants and to prevent in
people like tenants crashing properties
you just need to do your homework on
them like don't be a desperate landlord
or a desperate I'm motivated so a
landlord don't just take anybody get the
credit checks down and get speak to
previous previous references and don't
just get the reference from the previous
tenant the previous landlord sorry one
before get the one before and one before
that if possible because obviously that
previous one he wants rid of them so if
they are a bad tenant he's been telling
the brewing just to get rid so I would
always go for a few and just credit
checks you know credit checks show up a
lot yeah when you're doing your
referencing through your through your em
state agency she take a decent deposit
its basic stuff that a good estate
agency will handle it's fair and
obviously if they do trash it you can
evict them through either like we did
earlier section eight which is the
probably the proper way to do it yeah
but then you got the risk going to fight
it well yeah I mean it's let's just see
somebody causes 10,000 pounds of damage
in your property and you've evicted them
and what was the recourse from that I
mean small claims court take me through
small claims hmm and just listen look if
you're looking at this as a business
point of view the fact that they can't
afford it is not your problem what you
need to do is if somebody's cost 10
grand of damaging my property believe me
they won't small claims and believe me
I'll pursue that for as long as it takes
I'm ruthless I believe your stuff do you
promise that promise yeah I'm ruthless
with this sort of stuff because it's
complete disrespect of your properties
and if they prepare to damage that
they've got a B of the consequences yeah
so I would through the courts through
the high court the tenants so much going
in their favor I think to make the
landlord
not be able to have it done out of
contracts for a reason that might you
know valid valid reasons but Ravin to
fight it's just it is worrying because I
imagine there'll be a lot of landlords
when a wanted sell up now there'd be a
lot cheap properties coming to market I
reckon because of this well so the
landlords are going to want to offload
might be well actually they ask me that
they asked me three questions on the
facts if I come home the first one was
are you gonna be selling all your
properties and I said no would you now
be interested in doing holiday let's and
I said yes and what was the last one I
can't remember those three questions
they're they're doing a survey to try
and app are you less likely to take on
DSS I'm not a massive I'm not against
the SAS because you can't with a new
rule coming in yeah but I'm not against
that because if you're let's just
obviously with DSS you can request the
rent gets paid directly from them can
you
I thought you do home they have to prove
it they have I think I don't think they
do that anymore I might be wrong by
dancing they do but anyway no all
interesting stuff right it's now time
for this
[Music]
so in the news this week okay so the
title is I took my landlord to court and
won fifteen thousand pound how five
leads renters triumph over their
landlord and this went viral basically
I'm gonna sum up in a nutshell sum it up
in that he's supposed to go up yep
autism with uh whatever right so these
five students they have a property at
HTML property and leads they were
renting it paying their rent on time the
property was nothing wrong with property
it was in good condition it was heated
it was nice it was immaculate and they
decided to take the landlord to court
because he didn't have a HMO license and
they won fifteen thousand pounds in back
paid rent because he wasn't a licensed
HMO landlord okay
well the first thing I would say is
septum right it does serve him right
yeah it's a lesson to any HMO landlord
because that that is the fact that that
has now happened it's good it's gonna
set up recipes were gonna be looking it
is actually quite annoying that they've
had the fifteen thousand pound back
because to me they are just used in a
loophole or a law which has been okay I
know he broke the law but just being
students just trying to get as much out
of somebody as possible and then I can
imagine like John rabe all tuned up the
thing is it's kind of like it seems a
bit harsh
it does have been asked but at the end
of the day it should have licensed it
and you know and that's that's the rules
so the property was three three hundred
pound per person per month
the a year and a half after they moved
in Ben and his housemates were
celebrating he said that's this really
annoying they're celebrating like as a
victory after they successfully sued and
took their former landlord to court and
won fifteen thousand pound of their rent
back
a picture of Ben on Twitter on 29th
March 2019 showed all of them for the
six housemates we've been able to attend
the hearing raising the fist jubilantly
outside leeds town hall and then they
were they were excited about how they've
just took their ex landlord to court and
won all of our rent back so lived
rent-free for a year and a half
there's wrongs in both I think of
Sealand alam for not getting a license
but they've all Tinley said that the
property was in good condition there was
nothing wrong with it and they're just
being a little bit because could was do
they have fire doors and stuff like that
property was up to standard yes see if
it didn't if it wasn't safe I couldn't
kind of understand it because you could
say well look we've been paying for this
and it wasn't safe statement from the
boys I'd be lying if I said them this
wasn't a money motivated factor but we
all share a similar political beliefs
and don't think housing should be
commodified so that the left isn't they
they believe the John Raible would love
these people he'd actually hate them
because they wouldn't like John Mabel
because he's a landlord if a private
individual is going to profit from
property we at least got hold of them
accountant if a private individuals are
going to profit off property we've at
least got to be hold them accountable
for things they do bad it wasn't a
personal vendetta against the landlord
he just broke her rule of course it was
a personal vendetta it was it was money
listen they've already said that in they
are they said it an article quote from
them it was money orientated what's not
so that's against him it's personally
against his men and it's not personal
it's money isn't it's not like that I
think I don't I think we contradict what
they're saying so they've gone on but
how and it can't be commodified but
they've commodified it by basically
getting all the money back they're
making it our money-making scheme hmm so
yeah the but I think land was wrong he
should have been licensed oh I should
have a license but I think that what
they did was was not good no I think it
was I think it was just young
it's been when we went to Uganda we had
the accident and they were worried we're
gonna sue them we're just like no that
was stupid like yeah it's just it's
there's you don't want to kick someone
in order that to me yeah I like kicking
someone down because they're made of a
red tape mistake yeah in order it's just
they're profiting from somebody that
made a mistake now if they're like majnu
been the other way around
imagine if he'd managed to charge them
double rent the uproar was two would be
because they're students and he's our
rich landlord as we all as most
landlords probably watching this show
will know is that that's not actually
often the case no it's not
most landlords are just hard-working
people that have happened to use their
money wisely to invest in property yeah
they're not and that mean the night
could have crippled him yeah of course
could of that probably did [ __ ] them
to be honest anything be the thing being
right is I get it if he was a complete
rogue landlord and the house was in
disgusting condition and he had no care
for their safety but that's not the case
but the big lesson it's a big takeaway
is if you've got a HMO get all the rules
get it licensed they're not messing
around then he's be made a scapegoat
well the thing is that's the test case
isn't it so you're gonna get all these
other students who have run out if I
immediately they've used all the student
loan money and they've run out of money
so they want to go in the lash I'm
thinking of we fire and getting licensed
HMO it should be licensed now I would be
panicking yeah oh you know what don't
rent students you bet anyone could do
that yeah a professional professional
tenant could do that I find it quite
quite frustrating because all it is is
they've taken our they've just taken out
a bit of a bad situation and profited as
much as possible from it you just follow
the rules guys learn the rules follow
the rules don't just go into anything
half-assed and not paying it you need to
know what you're doing if you're gonna
invest in projects where landlord you
need to know the rules
yeah you need to be you know well at the
crash course Spence I'm talk but hit
chemours he always says about doing it
right from the beginning
ie fire doors fire safety so that so
that there is the properties do
so that if the rules do change you're
ready now obviously this was a it was
actually a six-bedroom probably not a
five bedroom property so it needed a
license it was never any question not
needing the license hmm and he's
obviously taking steps to make sure it
was licensable
but he just never actually got the
license so thousand-pound lesson do not
I mean yeah Boston 15 grand I do think
that the students took advantage yeah
it's not a nice it's rational and all
but it's it's a it's a hard lesson but
you have to take it on the chin where
he's gonna have to take it on the chin
right it's now time this okay so on this
week's question answers they've been
coming in thick and fast we'll get
through as many as we can so we'll start
by the way if you want to ask a question
in future get on the property investors
with Samuel Leeds Facebook group we do a
Facebook live
randomly on there where we ask for
questions go on post questions and we'll
get through as many as we can
so that's property investors with Samuel
EADS Facebook group okay first one I'm
gonna ask you this Alastair this is from
Harman bahir
hello Harman what's the state of the
property market currently we actually
touch on this reasonably regular I think
it's they're pretty strong at the minute
I think places are slowly going up yeah
I'm a little with bricks it happening or
not happening I don't know it's a little
bit uncertain and I think once bricks it
is a decisions to be made
I think prices will sort of fluctuate a
little bit they probably dipped a little
bit afterwards until it's sort of sorts
of self out so maybe for a few months
six months or whatever and I think
fundamentally the market is strong rents
are going up they're increasingly grown
up even in London their house prices are
recovering quite slightly and rents are
strong so I think scuffing it's good yep
I grow alright next okay we've got one
here from Anna Langford hey Anna I how's
Dave how you and Dave do you think the
recent rent change in tenant rules will
change anything for landlords yes we
just discussed that section 21 earlier I
do think it's gonna have quite an impact
but who knows because the government
haven't made yet a final decision on
when it's going to be implemented and
exactly what it involved
what it entails so I just have to watch
a space watch out for the industry news
and we'll see what happens when it
happens yeah I can't really I mean we've
talked about that quite a bit okay
here's a question for you kind of
relevant as well we were just talking
about okay this is from hedgerow you
know the joy the sea with a little dash
underneath it you know like yep yeah
how'd you pronounce that is it just a
sea still I don't know or would you like
to say like shout or something
is it like okay but anyway I'm gonna go
for just being a sea so it's Pedro gon
carves yeah I'm guessing it's not that
so apologies paid directly butchering
your name but Pedro is asked this hey
guys hey Pedro do you need any safety
measures for a four-bed for tenant HMO
or are they optional eg fire doors smoke
alarms fire extinguishers etc for this
for this type of HR at the moment well
I'll let you answer it right okay right
every single area has different rules
and so the first thing you need to do is
you need to pick your property wherever
it may be you need to speak to the local
HM or planning office and you tell them
what you're gonna be doing with the
property they will have a list of
amenity standards which which you have
to follow they'll have a good practice
guide for good landlords which will lay
out what they recommend for conversion
wise ie fire doors what you put you
requires good landlord and you have to
fall immunity standards I personally a
respect of where is in the country if
your housing multiple tenants it has to
have fire doors there's no question but
there is areas in the UK we don't
legally have to have them but there's
other ways we do so again you speak to
local authorities do essentially license
but I would always just do it it's not a
lot of money you're talking copper gran
to get your property compliant in the
sense of fire doors fire safety well you
go ask yourself Pedro yeah oh you guys
said Pedro if there's a fire in your
property and somebody dies how are you
gonna feel about that I'm gonna have a
pause for dramatic effect how are you
going to feel about that money
we have some outs got some flames I'll
sit on the screen when he says that try
say again we'll get some read really
dramatic okay you ready go it reacts
wouldn't do that
yeah alright start again no let's start
again this whole thing is gonna be in
the ceiling this well just do it so
Pedro
let me ask someone if you have a fire at
your property how are you gonna feel if
one of your tenants dies because you
didn't - a fire door although I don't
know at you Tony Pedro he's only asked a
very nice question hey Pedro how you
gonna feel huh
no seriously man and it's a great
question page it's a great question it's
very it's a bit of a gray area thing is
is that right now you I think you want
to err on the side of course because
it's like you say if there was a fire
and 300 quid for a fire door please just
fit fire doors to your hate chair malls
irrespective it's three bedroom or
twenty bedroom just fit fire doors for
the sake of 300 quid but check with you
don't work they'll to find out really
not worth the legal ramifications right
he go next one this is from Andrew McKee
hey Andrew
can you list the main things to get your
first time out up and running from
starting a brand new limited company
with a business partner to getting the
keys in your hand my company has no
financial history etc that's a long-ass
question it's not ok so you've got a
company set up yeah got your business
partner yeah go out and find a house you
don't need a business partner just a car
whatever I mean comedy set up yeah go
out find the property yeah
secure a mortgage yeah instructor
solicitor
yeah go through the surveys and land
searches complete on your house get a
bill team in to convert and do all their
work that needs requiring to make it
compliant and legal there ain't got your
keys speak to an accountant speak to a
lawyer speak the solicitor
especially just buy a house make sure
it's in an area that'll work reduce do
your research mainly make sure it's an
area it's a very open-ended question
because they we could sit here for the
next two hours talking about that and
did we not did we talk about hedgerow
thank you very slow recently a couple of
videos back
last week so if you go on the podcast
last week we actually break down how to
find you area how to add all about HMOs
I'm not sure he's really referring to
things that have defined areas I think
he's talking about how to get your first
teacher more up and running ie from
you've found the property two keys in
hand like a blue twill source we're
honest just follow the price it's not
actually just more the process just do
it
you could quite listen you've got a
limited company set up go and speak to
our mortgage broker get get advice on a
mortgage and speak to our tax accountant
to get a face how you're going to buy
that property go and find a property put
your offer and get the solicitors to do
all the work land searches registry
office all that sort of stuff bang
you've got these big man such aggression
guys thank you very much for tuning in
this week we'll be back next Saturday at
7 p.m. don't forget to subscribe comment
below what you thought the show and we
will see you next week
see you guys
[Music]
[Applause]